>> And in coming up to this answer David used some background knowledge.
The background knowledge that he used was that the bricks that were
in the vertical position in the first example, and the cylinders that were in
the vertical position in the third example, and the special blocks that are in
the vertical position in this example. Are all examples of something called
a block. They can be replaced by each other. So instead of having a brick,
one could have a cylinder, or some other thing that's vertically placed here.
Now, someone else in the class may have a different background knowledge, and
he or she may not consider this to be an example of a block, in which
case the answer might be no. The point here being that background knowledge is
playing an important role in deciding whether or not this is an example of foo.